hey guys welcome back to your weekly dev
stream recap and today I probably have
some of the best news you will ever hear
about for honor in your life at this
moment so let's get to it let's I'm
wasting your time and definitely want to
stick around to the end of the video so
let's get started so first up the new
weekly content is new elite outfits for
all character social that's you right
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
those are alright those are going to
cost in seven case few if you want to
buy them let me know what you think
about those in the comments I'm not
really too big on elite outfit to myself
though anyway the newest public test
that's going to be coming out for PC
players only is next week this is going
to include tons of defensive medicine
jizz which we will discuss later in the
video so please be sure to stick around
for that next up a new game-mode is
being tested as an event tomorrow which
is called realistic Dominion which is
Dominion with no HUD no radar no gear
stats and no revives so it's basically
going to be a kind of hardcore Dominion
so be interesting how that plays out the
the new call to event order is also
going to be this new game-mode as well
so try to play as many realistic
Dominion matches as you can this week
and then we can get or this weekend and
we can get our 2000 steel
next up warlord and Raider are going to
be receiving a nerf to their unblockable
sprint move Stampede charge 4 Raider and
crashing charge for warlord basically
the minimum connection is now 300
milliseconds instead of 100 milliseconds
making it so that Raider and warlord
players have to be in the animation just
slightly longer now to grab the player
because in yesterday's video we
discussed how both the characters need
only one frame of activation for it to
work so they're changing that now also
with this patch revenge is finally going
to be taken out of duels about goddamn
time this is going to be in patch 1.09 1
which will we be releasing today for
everybody I hope I hope it's today PC
users already have 1.09 but console
users have yet to receive that so PC
players are going to be getting 1.0 9.1
today and council will be getting 1.09
and 1.09 1 today for them that's a
mouthful I'm sorry about that let's
continue on also one really quick note
which is once again one of the best news
you'll ever hear one of the directors
Luke Duchene head stated that for honor
has 1.3 million players that played last
month 1.3 million and now these are
unique players so that means if I log in
twice throughout the month it doesn't
count as too long
it's only one so that means 1.3 actual
actual real people played this game so
the whole foreigners dead comments can
go [ __ ] off now because clearly that
means this game is in dead nor is it
even close to being dead anyway
catch 1.10 is coming next week to all
platforms and this is just one of those
classic title updates it's going to be
improving connection for all three
platforms and it's supposed to fix
unlock tech but who knows because as
soon as that one got fixed there was
more unlocked actively found so no
promises with that it was probably
really no promises with connection
either so we'll just have to find it
find out and wait next up for the public
test it will include a 1v1 tournament
like last time and a for V for Dominion
is going to be added now the changes for
this public test of the defensive meta
which we talked about and in the
beginning and this is what they're
changing their changing parrying guard
break stamina shift image revenge and
zone flicker not to be specific for
parrying the parry window is shorter
making it harder to do and it's a little
bit more safer to get pair if you're
being parried off a light attack and
it's going to be treated as a heavy
attack so it's a little bit of a nerf
and a little bit of a kind of a buff I
don't know how to expertly explain that
but guard break it is up next and it's
no longer going to be guaranteed after a
parry that's really the only thing for
guard break as of yet for stamina
stamina regen unblock and on dodge are
going to be paused making your stamina
not regen and while standing still and
blocking attacks out of stamina
punishment if you remember is when your
health bar goes gray this makes players
way more vulnerable than before you
cannot parry while out of stamina and
this makes out of being out of stamina
super dangerous to be in so just be wary
to never get in that during this public
test shift image is up next and chip
damage is going to be increased by 18
percent for any attack used in it it
cannot kill anybody but it will bring
their health to one HP now for nobody
that for anybody that doesn't know chip
damage is actually been in the game
since the beginning but it's only done
about one HP and it's practically
useless so that's why they're increasing
it to 18 percent so hopefully it's not
too much we'll just have to wait and see
and then next up is revenge and you
cannot be interrupted by melee attack 1
revenge the shield from revenge is now
70% more instead of 50% more for your
shield outgoing attacks from revenge
cannot be parried basically making you
an unstoppable force also any non
damaging attack such as shove headbutt
and leg sweep will finally be
interrupted by revenge mode activation
and then the last one is own flicker you
already know what I'm about to say it's
gone thank God
although rip while you Orochi means
because that's really one of the only
things you really had was that flicker
so sucks for you guys but it had to be
done now guys remember that these
patches are only on the public test
server that's going to be happening next
week Thursday so any of you PC players
pick up the game recently or I've had it
you can test these out you can always
share in the comments if these are worth
it or not I'll be checking around reddit
probably making the video if these are
worth it or not but if these are good
and they're working as intended they
will be released into the full game for
everybody to enjoy so let's hope that
this goes through and works also for the
duel tournament for the people that are
PC players here they're fixing issues
from the last test such as losing too
much ring from a fight or not gaining
enough rank during a fight and then now
abandoning a tournament will have you
will have harsher punishments than last
time and the ranking system whatever you
queue up for a game it'll be within one
rank lower or higher or even of yours
making the matches a lot more even and
fair and that's about it guys is a
really really informational dead stream
it was super super exciting talking
about the huge player base that we still
have I thought we had about 100k people
playing I'm not going to lie to you I
didn't realize we had over 100 million
or 1 million people playing and then
this new the public test server stuff
going out with chip damage zone flicker
being gone all this stuff to parrying
and gar braking and stamina it's going
to be good but with these changes it's
basically going to be like you're
playing a new game a little bit like as
if we never played for honor with all
these insane it changes with Perry
timing and such so if you have any
friends that have left the game for
player base or anything hit them up show
them this video and just tell them to
come back to the game because everyone's
basically going to be starting fresh if
this gets released
full game anyway guys one thing I want
to note is that next week is when the
dead stream comes out on Thursday it
will be uploaded a little bit later than
usual I have some personal issues to
take care of so it might be an hour
later than you expect so I do apologize
for that I try to get these videos for
you guys as quick as I can so I'm sorry
if it's a little later than usual but it
will still be out for you guys to watch
anyway like the video if you guys did
enjoy dislike it if you didn't sub to
the channel if you're new hit the bell
right next to it tickets a couple
seconds but you'll also get
notifications for me so that you never
miss one of my uploads and my most
recent videos popping up on screen and
the top right for you guys to watch and
with that I hope you all enjoyed and
I'll see you later good bye